[Música]
continuamos con nuestra agenda del día y
en directo américa la salud es por
cuenta de mar romero buen día para usted
madre y vamos a hablar de un hito en la
historia de la ciencia por primera vez
se logró secuenciar el genoma humano y
de manera completa buenos días ángeles
pues efectivamente de hecho es un
momento y una noticia bastante
emocionante que quién sabe qué
implicaciones llegará a tener a futuro
el genoma es la secuencia total del
material genético en este caso de los
humanos es decir que podemos hablar de
que es una especie del libro de
instrucciones para entender cómo
funcionamos como somos y entonces pues
finalmente se ha logrado secuenciar ese
cien por cien de esta información
genética hasta ahora se tenía el 92 por
ciento lo hizo un consorcio llamado t 2
t que agrupó el trabajo de
aproximadamente un centenar de
científicos y finalmente este trabajo se
publicó ayer en la revista science para
que todos podamos pues leerlo y
entenderlo esta es una información
bastante preliminar pero que se conoce
de la parte del genoma que ya ha sido
descubierta pues ahora falta mucha
investigación como decías no porque por
ahora es como sí las piezas y tenemos
que entender qué hacen esas piezas y
cómo interactúan con el resto del genoma
y con nuestro cuerpo pero ese 8% de
genoma que se ha descubierto incluye
bastante información estamos hablando
por ejemplo de un centenar de genes
codificantes activos qué significa eso
pues que son genes que efectivamente
producen proteínas la proteína es el
lenguaje que luego entiende el cuerpo
para reproducir una función que le está
indicando ese gen además de esos 100 que
se sabe que son codificantes y que son
activos también hay unos 2000 genes que
se van a tener que estudiar más en
detalle pero que se saben pues que
también se han descubierto en ese 8% y
además también se han identificado unos
2 millones de variantes genéticas hasta
ahora desconocidas es decir 2 millones
de lugares donde la información genética
puede variar de persona a persona una
información que hasta ahora no se tenía
es importante destacar que ese 8% de
material genético que se desconocía
equivale prácticamente a un cromosoma
entero que no sabía pues cómo estaba
estructurado ni que hacía bueno y
precisamente porque había sido tan
difícil hasta el momento secuenciar el
genoma completo
porque las partes que estaban sin
secuenciar ese 8% del que hablábamos
eran partes muy repetitivas de hecho los
investigadores lo describían como
intentar montar un puzzle de un cielo
azul donde las piezas se parecen
muchísimo pero encajan de maneras
particulares las unas con las otras y
por eso había sido tan difícil entender
llegar a entender qué pasaba con esas
partes pero es que además el genoma no
es nada sencillo son unos 23 pares de
cromosomas 46 cromosomas en dos parejas
en 23 parejas perdón estos cromosomas
entre otras cosas tienen esos genes que
son la información pues que indica el
funcionamiento de gran parte de nuestro
cuerpo y esos genes están formados por
lo que llamamos bases son dos como
cuatro moléculas que se emparejan de
determinadas maneras haciendo esta
estructura de hélice que muchos tenemos
en mente cuando hablamos del adn y esas
cuatro moléculas cada una tiene una
letra para hacernos una idea sabemos que
hay tres mil cincuenta y cinco millones
de esos pares de letras si las
pusiéramos todas seguidas habría
suficiente letras como para llenar unas
dos mil copias del libro del quijote por
ejemplo entonces pues así podemos
entender que los esfuerzos para
descifrar el genoma aún hayan empezado
hace tanto tiempo alrededor de 1990 pues
han sido difíciles y de hecho pues
todavía van a seguir hacia adelante y en
esas revisiones así el futuro qué
implicaciones podría tener este
descubrimiento marc pues tocará que se
vayan revelando y que los científicos
también hagan su trabajo con esta nueva
información con este nuevo mapa genético
que tenemos pero por ahora lo que
podemos intuir es cómo están
relacionadas o sea qué zonas son las que
se han esclarecido y qué funciones
cumplen hablemos de estos cromosomas que
decíamos una de las partes que más
esclarecidos lo que se llama el centro
el centro mero perdón que es donde se
cruzan las equis del cromosomas ahí es
donde había tanta información repetida y
son partes esenciales para la
reproducción celular para la división
celular cuando las células se
multiplican entonces son partes
esenciales por ejemplo en la formación
de óvulos de espermatozoides y sabemos
que los errores en esas zonas son las
que se pueden provocar por ejemplo
malformaciones congénitas o incluso
abortos espontáneos entonces esclarecer
qué ocurre y seguro dará muchas pistas
en estos ámbitos también en los
telómeros que como ven en las imágenes
son el extremo de esas equis y ahí esos
telómeros son los que se achican con el
envejecimiento pero en cambio se alargan
con enfermedades como el cáncer o en las
células tumorales y cancerosas entonces
en esos dos ámbitos también podría haber
nueva información y por supuesto pues
como decíamos tener este mapa genético
seguro también va a representar un gran
avance en toda la medicina alrededor de
la genética y de las enfermedades que
son hereditarias extremadamente
interesante y lo que me queda es que
después de descubrir este 100 por ciento
del genoma lo que queda es trabajo pues
exactamente porque de hecho está estas
secuencias de un solo genoma además de
un genoma de ascendencia europeo
podríamos decirle un genoma blanco
sabemos que las variaciones son mínimas
entre distintas personas pero igual
queda muchísimo por entender es solo un
genoma repetimos que sirve de referencia
para todas las personas entonces pues lo
que hará falta será poder repetir este
trabajo con otras personas con múltiples
personas para tener una imagen cada vez
más completa pues muchas gracias a usted
por esta primicia de la ciencia pues que
nos llena de emoción y sobre todo de
incógnitos hacia el futuro y pues es el
momento del invitado del día así que
seguimos